my name is chef Anita hell actually
means in German right so it kind of fits
very nicely with optics light propagates
as a wave and because it propagates as a
wave a lens cannot focus the light onto
a focal point and I dramatically for the
point so people thought that you
couldn't image more sharply than say
half the wavelength of light because of
its phenomenon but it was a
misconception you can do that if you
you're not using the focusing of light
as a means to separate features what I
discovered is that you can do the
separation of features just by turning
them on and off and that works
particularly nicely for fresh scent
molecules because you can turn off their
fluorescence normally molecules are in
the so called ground state meaning
either a state in which they are not
capable of emitting light back but if
you shine light of them they get excited
to specific and then they release their
excitation energy by emitting a photon
of threatened light and this is why they
go so by playing with these two
different states on and off glowing and
not going you can make them discern the
moon by by just making sure that not all
of them glow at the same time when you
eat and with light the first thing that
was actually seen as a great level of
detail was tiny vesicles in in neurons
so these are little little containers
they're about 30 nanometers across in
diameter and they contain molecules that
absolutely critical for transmitting
signals between neurons and you can see
the mouth
they move and are they they bounce about
if you like and so there are many many
discoveries that have been made and are
being made all the time because we can
see now things in a much greater length
of detail
the beautiful bay above tree or Tree of
Life is an African icon the baobab fruit
contains four times of potassium of
banana three times the vitamin C of an
orange and twice the calcium of spinach
but the Bale Bob is an orphan science
has paid little attention to this tree
until now the African orphan crops
consortium is harnessing the power of
genetics for orphan crops the bail Bob
tree is the first of 101 plants to have
its genome sequence assembled and
annotated and the information will be
made available to all unrestricted where
millions of people are malnourished this
genetic data will help farmers provide
the food they need the genomes will
guide African plant breeders so they can
create crops that are higher yielding
water and nutrient use sufficient
resilient to climate change and full of
nutrition triggering a huge leap forward
for the diversity and sustainability of
the continents agriculture